Speaker 1: going back to Cuba momentarily.
David, what should Joe Biden do about Cuba?
That's a very American centric way to ask
the question, and I think it's important to
start with first.
Joe Biden doesn't necessarily have to do anything
about Cuba in the sense that the United States
doesn't have to be involved in every issue
in every country.
That's a starting point.
That's not isolationist.
That's we we just we don't have to be involved
everywhere all the time.
Now, you might say.
Hold on a second, David.
The U.S. is already involved in Cuba because
of the embargo and for other reasons.
It's already entangled.
And I would agree with you 100 percent.
And we'll get into that in a second.
But the first point is reframing.
Joe Biden doesn't have to do anything about
what's going on in any particular country
by definition now, because part of why Cuba
is the way it is today, part of.
Is related to the American embargo of Cuba,
at absolute minimum, Joe Biden should be getting
rid of the amped up sanctions that Donald
Trump put in.
Barack Obama had eased those sanctions.
Donald Trump had reinstated some of those.
Joe Biden should immediately step back from
those.
At the same time, the U.S. simply cannot and
by cannot I mean, should not it's a moral
question, should not be involved in any kind
of influence.
Campaign for regime change in Cuba, American
involvement in regime change in Central Latin
and South America.
However, you want to slice and dice that region
of the world has been almost exclusively a
disaster.
And there are so many, so many stories of
that.
You can look at Columbia, you can look to
a lesser degree in Argentina, Nicaragua, Honduras.
I mean, there's just so, so many questions.
So my preference would be because, remember,
I'm a progressive, anti authoritarian.
My tendencies are not fascist, my tendencies
are not authoritarian.
They're not dictatorial.
I'm a small l progressive libertarian.
I can't support any regime that's been in
power since nineteen fifty nine and that was
handed from one brother to another.
It doesn't matter if what it was replacing
was bad.
It doesn't matter if it was, if it was replacing
something that was supported by the US in
the fifties.
I'm a progressive libertarian so it's a there
are certain principles that are really important.
And one is I don't support dictatorial regimes,
police states, etc.
So the US should not support the Castro regime,
but should have zero involvement in regime
change operations.
But beyond that, I don't know that I'm hugely
inclined to say the U.S. should have a bigger
and bigger role.
I would love to see U.S. aid leveraged and
used.
Other nonprofit groups are eager to helping
Cuba make it easier for them to do that.
Send food aid, send medical aid.
I know some people say Cuba doesn't need any
medical aid, but they do.
They do.
But beyond that, I am very skeptical of American
involvement in Cuba because it has been pretty
disastrous for a long time.
If you I know it bums me out, but there are
some authoritarian leftists.
Are they really leftists?
I know.
I know that that's a question you will ask.
But there are some self-described leftists
who are authoritarian in my audience who have
a different perspective on Cuba.
They really like the Castro regime.
It's tough for me to find common ground with
that because I just can't support any kind
of autocratic police state type regime that's
lasted sixty years.
I just I just can't do it.
I can't you know, I don't support that in
North Korea.
I don't support it.
It's shorter and different.
But in Venezuela and I don't support it in
Cuba either.
Send me your thoughts.
What should or should not Joe Biden be doing
in Cuba?
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Get instant access.
Really?
Come on in.
We've got an extra show every day by signing
up at Join Packenham.